during the pandemic i asked the same
first two questions
um what tv series would each of you like
to guest star on
oh wow really i would have to say like i
watch a lot of like
tv series from i mean not yesteryear
they're not like that all but i i think
i would probably say sex in the city but
like that
is you know i would like like in like
back when it was happening you know
um that i would have to i would love to
like go to lunch with the ladies
i would like to uh co-star or guest star
on
uh ken burns upcoming docu-series about
covet
okay that was a way more serious answer
than i was expecting
i was like wow um i haven't been
watching so much tv
uh other question is what movie or
movies do you think you've seen the most
probably the wizard of oz i've seen the
wizard of oz like
it was my favorite movie when i was like
little like really really little
and my parents always remind me about
how like they used to like i used to
watch it
literally over and like it would like
end and they would like put the
like tape like back in like literally
over and over and over again when i was
little because i loved it so much so
that's probably the one i've seen the
most
great movie maybe like e.t or something
like that i mean
i was like classic as a kid watched over
and over and over
jumping into why i get to talk to you
guys um i really enjoy
movies that sort of ask questions about
the future
and like basically this movie is not
science fiction as much as it's
a real possibility as to what might
happen
down the road on our planet can you sort
of talk about that aspect
of voyagers sure i i think that's
you know the most attractive aspect of
the film you know like we
i think uh innately just have this
intrinsic fascination with things that
might happen in our future
and i think this movie is definitely
operating in that realm
and uh yeah the movie is about a a group
of people
you know who we find them at 18 years
old who've been sent on a mission
into space and to reach a distant planet
but only 90 years down the road right so
they're never
their whole purpose is to have children
that will then have children that would
then colonize the planet
um so it's uh yes i think it's the
premise in itself
is fascinating you know and then it's
hyper focused around
these characters and their true natures
you know and they're and so it's very
has a very
human element to it as well which is
interesting i think that that
fascination for you know the future and
and what might
become of it is is something that also
like you know our characters share
because
like you know like ty was saying they're
they're not going to see the planet you
know their grandchildren will see the
planet
and so i think they too you know knowing
that their entire lives are going to be
spent on this ship
working towards uh you know the the a
mission that they're never going to see
fully come to fruition you know i think
that probably inspires a lot of kind of
uh fascination in them also about like
what is this future
going to look like because we're not
going to be the ones the ones
experiencing it you know what will our
grandchildren's
lives look like when they when they
reach the planet and so i think that
that's a
a fascination that that both our
characters and also our
you know probably our the the audience
will will share
one of the things i took away from
watching the film is that um
and i don't want to do spoilers but
there's a bit in the movie
where people are presented with facts
and they choose to
avoid them or just not even acknowledge
the facts that they're presented with
and i found it very timely with what's
gone on in the real world over the last
number of months
um and you obviously couldn't have known
what the real world was going to look
like when you made this film but
this film talks about the real world in
a in an interesting way
i think that's something that's that's
evident in human nature
you know um throughout the course of our
you know our documented lives you know
this this you know someone's ability to
you know jump to a conclusion without
having their own reason
you know to jump on the bandwagon per se
and i think that's what
neil was really interested in exploring
in this film
um you know the the
uh and so i i think you know even
there's that but there's also
um you know other other elements that
that i think are
it's the movies really stripped down you
know and it takes away
there is no really societal uh resonance
you know the
cultural resonance these these
characters they have
no there's no tangible um relationship
to
to the world that they come from and
then they're kind of
you know um they're in isolation on this
spaceship you know
going to on this mission going to
colonize this planet so it's like
they're
they're in a bit of like no man's land
you know so it makes the story
really focused on these characters and
our true nature so
i think there definitely is a is an
aspect of like
who do we trust you know when we're
being presented with
truth or fact it's like how you know
whose truth
is that and where is that coming from
and i think that you know on the ship
there's a lot of kind of
you know as we see kind of come to
fruition and in the story like it's like
uh
all of a sudden they they're they're
being presented with you know
they're being presented with the
opportunity to kind of question that
truth for the first time and and
think about you know what really is
going on and why are we being told these
things and why you know and and who
really are we supposed to be
um trusting so i think that that is
something that plays into
uh the kind of madness that that ensues
is how everybody you know chooses to
approach that
thank you so much for your time congrats
on the movie you both did a really good
job
um good luck with the rest of your speed
dating
have a great day